flip
hi guys it's ria you guys have been
requesting me to recreate a recipe from
cookie mama so today i'm making pudding
from cookie mama so while we are looking
what recipe to do we came across this
youtuber called game team and he has
done a lot of cookie mama video so you
guys have to check it out so i'm super
excited for this challenge but i don't
play video game at all so today my
friend duck from
buzzfeed multiplayer to help me out
thanks for having me yeah thank you for
coming of course let's play it all right
let's do it
go ahead and hit start okay
you'll click that
and you might have to explain what some
of these things are to me honestly this
is milk so in japan my mom she get
delivered fresh milk every day oh wow it
looks like that yeah so see the arrow so
you're just gonna swipe that way at
least that's what i think it wants you
to oh yeah there you go all right it
gets harder i think okay so now break we
gotta break the eggs whoa that does not
seem like how you would break an egg in
in real life okay hey three stars yeah
we have the milk and the eggs mix it so
you just like oh yeah you're putting
sugar in it and milk
oh now you like grab it from there and
then do like a yeah exactly
all the way up okay so you have to do it
like yeah
three stars again okay so now
okay
what do i do swipe that up oh oh but
like carefully
and we've only filled up wow okay so you
shouldn't overfill yeah what's going to
happen if i overfill oh no
okay it's fine it's fine okay so you
have to turn on the stove i think and
then keep hitting it
oh too soon
uh-oh wait finished
okay this is the last step oh wow be
careful how fast and then just okay
oh here we go oh and a little uh a
little cherry amazing job so the game is
my expertise and i can't cook at all so
i'm gonna just uh let you do that and
then we'll come back i'm gonna come back
and eat
okay so let's try
so to make this challenge more authentic
i wanted to dress up like cookie mama i
got pink headband i got yellow apron and
i have mama title under my belt we have
a camera set up looking like a game and
i'm ready the first step we're gonna do
is not in the game i'm going to make
camera from scratch like traditionally
but i'm also going to use caramel tablet
later then we're going to see which one
works better cup of sugar pour into the
pot quarter cup of water first i'm going
to just wet all the sugar so
it's evenly coated with water turn on
the heat to medium so don't start it
when you stir it it crystallizes it and
it's become like kind of chunky sugar
crystals not smooth caramel it will
takes about seven to ten minutes visual
cue is when it's become like nice brown
umber color sugar caramelized i'm going
to pour into this cute ramekin i'm using
cooking spray so it doesn't stick
for over like three tablespoons okay so
caramel it's done next i'm going to
crack some eggs in a game cookie mama
was cracking in the air
also i don't recommend to crack egg like
this much i can try it
but you will get
shell
basically you want to crack eggs on the
first surface
so you don't get shells in japanese we
call this pudding
p-u-r-i-n i think we kind of adapted
english water pudding it sounded like
pudding to us eggs are ready i'm going
to go get my milk in the game cookie
mama was using cute milk in a jar this
step is also not in the game but i want
to make sure sugar is completely
dissolved so i'm going to heat up milk
in a pan i want to make sure to make
perfectly smooth pudding so i'm using my
technique in here i think i get sad face
from mama i spill some milk and
sugar
and vanilla medium low heat because
sugar sometimes spar on the bottom so
just like bring up to like gentle simmer
sugar is completely dissolved in the
game they just pour milk over and
stirring what i want is a smooth pudding
so i want to whisk the egg first i don't
want to pour hot milk at once because it
will cook the egg and it doesn't become
a pudding it's become a scrambled egg so
i'm doing little by little maybe i don't
get three stars from cookie mama but i
think i get three stars from pastry chef
cooking mama is pretty cross in
terms of you know how to cook and how to
make pudding they are more focused on
how to play games so there is like you
know hiccups here and there but i think
it's pretty good recipe i think
everything is incorporated but it's a
little bit frosty on the surface so i'm
going to strain
so it doesn't have any chunky egg okay
so this is ready so i'm going to go get
my ramekins next i want to try with this
caramel tablet spray some oil caramel
tablet i don't know what it is but i'm
assuming caramel flavor candy and i was
told this is something american grandma
always have in the past four things
for the egg mixture
i have one more for comparison i think
if you're cooking with kids at home this
park is amazing if it works but i don't
know so this one is the one i made
earlier it's the camera from scratch and
i have three more so i'm gonna fill
with this egg mixture don't overfill it
like i did in a game i noticed there are
some bubbles and frost on top of the
pudding you can torch and kill all the
bubble or you can use paper towel so
you're kind of like catching all the
frost like that another step it wasn't
in a game i want to cover with aluminium
foil if you steam and if we don't cover
it all the moisture all the water go
into this ramekin and you don't want
that i think this is not the fun part of
the game either so i can see why they're
skipping this part okay i'm ready and
i'm going to steam these puddings i have
my steam already gently simmering right
now this is the part i messed up in the
game because i wasn't sure what i was
doing so basically you have to turn the
heat up to bring the water to a boil and
then lower the heat and bring it to a
simmer so you can gently steam the
pudding we are going to steam this 11 to
13 minutes put the lid on top visual cue
the outside is setting but the middle
part is still jiggly so we're gonna just
wait until it's cooked so we can get
that mama smiley face so we cooked the
pudding about 11 to 13 minutes and then
we cool it to room temperature and put
it in a refrigerator and we chill it
about one hour so it is now hold we are
ready to unmold now kinda want to try
how she did but i'm pretty sure if i
just smash into the play it's going to
be a mess so what i want to try
it's just like
flip
nothing comes out so that technique
doesn't work i'm going to just like use
offset spatula so you're kind of
releasing from the side so it's easier
to unmold this is the one we used
caramel tablet aka grandma's candy
oh
look it's still candy packed on the
bottom but you know what this created
perfect for for cherry so i'm going to
put cherry
this is incredible it's just like let's
see right into it also the indicator for
perfect pudding you want to see like
very smooth surface and we did it mama
will be proud of me so let's try
the one i made with caramel from scratch
and i have another trick that i want to
show you put this upside down and you're
gonna just
spin
at least should walk i'm a little dizzy
but
it will set see
you don't need anything you just need
yourself
spin and it comes up they definitely
should put in a spin part in the game
there is a no perfect haul so i'm not
sure if it's gonna stand so if you want
to put cherry in a perfect shape like
cookie mama
i recommend to use caramel tablet
because it creates perfect haul but if
you're going for taste i highly
recommend make caramel from scratch and
i'm gonna taste it before that comes
nice smooth surface i like it
tastes just like my childhood food i'm
going to bring back zak and see what he
thinks
are you excited very excited all right
oh my god
that is amazing that really looks just
like it was it similar besides like
throwing the a guys we tweak
a little wow good job thank you
so please enjoy my gosh i've been
waiting all day for this okay here we go
three stars nailed it
amazing thank you so much for watching
and let us know what recipe we should
recreate from a video game
next
bye
oh yes
[Music]
you